My hemoglobin is a bit low, and the oncologist recommend doing an iron infusion, as I am currently
doing a low dose chemo pump, and there's a chance it could drop even more.
I do not want the infusion.
What supplement would you recommend instead?
Also, I am not received the resulted full genetic report as it did not come through either
email.
Thank you.
I didn't read this question, unfortunately, I don't read these questions before I actually
am talking to you right now, so I will have to look back and see who said this and get
you your supplement report or the genetic report.
The genetic report is like 250 pages down.
Sometimes it doesn't end up attaching, so if you didn't get it just let us know.
So if your hemoglobin is low enough that they would recommend an iron infusion, it's
probably below 8.
Nothing supplement wise, it's going to raise your hemoglobin faster than doing an infusion.
So I personally would do the infusion if it was me.
That's going to raise your hemoglobin up.
That's going to actually make you feel better, give you more energy, you're going to feel
better and be safer.
If you're going to just take iron and do the iron emissited program, it's going to be very
slow raising your hemoglobin, you can do that as well, but I personally would do the infusion.
And if you're like set against it, you don't feel like you're led to do that, then I would
use our iron emissited program and the iron that we use is called clear iron.
It's our product or reacted iron, the ortho molecular product, or the desides for health has
an iron, it's the exact same thing, the reverence, it's a tracts product from the good products
where it was that is the albioted tracts, so the good supplements are using, good supplement
companies are using literally the exact same base substance, that I put out of the things
in it, but it's still the iron itself, the mineral itself is going to be tracts or albioted.